thank you for joining us i'm john
langler nascar is back in las vegas
tonight a weekend of racing gets
underway up at the speedway with
some fans in the stands kate houston
looks at the valley's biggest event
since the pandemic started
tonight more than ten thousand fans will
fill these stands behind me
and although there's health and safety
guidelines in place the speedway says it
will be a fun
and engaging experience for everybody
here
[Music]
sound nascar fans haven't heard in
person for many months
it's exciting we're ready to be back to
racing drivers will be competing in
front of a sold out crowd each night
drawing in fans from out of town and
right here in las vegas
patrick perniak set up an entire
entertainment area outside of his rv
with tvs grills and cornhole
to promote his business and enjoy
watching the races
last night people are out and about
they're they're walking around they're
riding their bikes and scooters you
wouldn't tell there's there's anything
different it's
social distancing at its best fans will
have to follow strict health protocols
while inside the speedway
and in the rv area gary mckay has been
coming to the races for the past
20 years as a lifelong fan he says it's
worth
it to be back with his friends and
family great to come back see people
here because last night we met a bunch
over on the other side so we sat there
and partied with them you know they're
from california we're from utah and so
it's just
it's getting to be just one big family
like thing again like it used to be
the first race kicks off tonight at six
nascar says the drivers will be bringing
it up a notch knowing fans are back in
the stands
kate houston 8 news now